sie saß mir sechseinhalb jahre in
isolationshaft sogar wie war die zeit
für sie und wer hat sie dort auf den
richtigen weg gebracht war sehr hart
muss ich sagen das ist eine maximale
mentale belastung ich glaube das würde
auch nicht jeder durchstehen ich wusste
dass auch nicht das weiß man erst machen
naja war aber der situation geschuldet
der sicherheitslage damals einfach um
weil sie jetzt grund sein und 9
denn auch acht
weitere sind auf der flucht fiel auch
gelesen sie sich mit mir selbst
auseinandergesetzt es gab dort einen
sozialarbeiter wenn mir sehr geholfen
hat damals und das war sehr wichtig
deswegen meinte ich auch es ist wichtig
dass man jemanden hat der einst ein
bisschen raus führt aus dieser
schwierigen und dunklen zeit muss man
dazu sagen es ist keine schöne zeit egal
wie man sich das schön redet ich wurde
verurteilt würden expected damals den
berühmt-berüchtigten wettbüro mord in
reinickendorf wo es eigentlich mit
einbegriffen in den laden gegangen sind
dort einen konkurrenten erschossen haben
[Musik]